what's up my babies it's episode 170 of
congratulations
[Music]
yeah I just want to see if the key map
worked and it does do the key Mackworth
works and it's sensational it's episode
170 this is like the fifth episode or
sixth or seventh episode of us in
quarantine wand fire and one end and I
even get rid of they are in they are
remote and one fire is in the car and
that's why he's one fire and when I push
my [ __ ] headphones up I look like a
[ __ ] out fell foot because the shits
come up come up dude yeah anyway I was
talking to my friend earlier and I think
maybe we're both not balding so it's all
good anyway uh we we convinced ourselves
each other that we both are balding and
it's all good so that's good man isn't
that funny when you do that with your
friend when you're like oh man you know
it's like it's like are you got a pretty
good head of hair and what you mean is
like we think about my hair so we do
that so that's cool we did that but he's
10 years older than me so hopefully I
mean I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about and the person is not
Bryan Callen because he absolutely is
going bald so actually he's probably not
he's like 53 and he's still good um I
don't know man you know we talk a lot of
[ __ ] about him but we love them we love
him my baby's got all my drinks over
here off camera can't see him got about
four or five drinks so that's really
great love having drinks here at the
graduation studios www.catecosta.com
congratulations pod comm not sure if
it's pot or podcast haven't been on the
website for oil but anyway
still kicking dude still friggin kicking
still kickin baby can't stop I mean
we're not actually kicking you know I
need people to say they're kicking women
will still live and do it because
this quarantine quarantine can't stop us
and by us I mean the people who it
hasn't stopped yet because some people
this this coronaviruses absolutely
stopped them people have been on
ventilators and people have been on on
bed rest for a long time and that's very
bad and that's very sad and I feel bad
for them and I hope that this [ __ ] and
soon I don't know if it will now they're
saying it's created on a lab which makes
it much scarier yes dude yes they said
it was from a bat out in the [ __ ] war
on market everywhere or a snake or some
[ __ ] or an eel and now they're saying it
was created in the lab which is much
more scary oh [ __ ] yeah dude yes it was
created in a lab so that means that
humans made it and then [ __ ] weren't
responsible enough to keep it indoors
dude that's so great man do we live in a
James Bond movie yes we do do it is this
quantum solace congratulations yes it is
dude quantum so quantum solace
congratulations
although the virus got out of the doors
now what do we do one man trying to stop
this virus oh no see if it [ __ ] it
went all over the place
oh god damn it Oh crikey oh and all over
the place don't don't don't ain't at
first they thought it was a bat Oh for
[ __ ] sake it's not about is it then
change stenting it's alright we're in
the lab and it's fine and it's not
getting out no matter what
no thanks thanks tank tank tank
the doors open crikey close it quick
she'll be okay four days later haha
thanks dang stone this summer prepare to
be quarantined
dude when they do that when they do that
[ __ ] prepare to be this summer prepare
to be [ __ ] prepared in but anyway to
feel real bad for you guys that have
that on your [ __ ] a horizontal if
you're on your horizontal we feel bad
for you if you're on your horizontal and
you're not [ __ ] if you're on your
horizontal on your dick ain't wet you
got you got Rona and we're sorry dude
then then then then if you're horizontal
and your dick ain't wet sorry you got
Rona
then dude guess what it's a nighttime
podcast or firing on all cylinders
sleeping or your [ __ ] [ __ ] sweat or
you got that Rona
anyway dude it's like dude this picture
with Mike Pence where everyone's wearing
the [ __ ] mask and he's not wearing a
mask hey dude put a mask on Italy you
know you're just gonna piss everyone off
you know you're just gonna piss everyone
off there's a guy in a [ __ ] recliner
in front of you wearing a mask
he's relaxing so obviously it's not a
big deal to wear a mask everyone else
has a mask on and this dude's like I'm
not gay I hate gays put a mask on dude
put a [ __ ] mask on it's so ridiculous
that he's not wearing a mask because
he's the VP and he's the man is that
what it is dude
you're the man dude you're like five
eight you know Trump's tall though dude
Trump's a bunch of potatoes but he's
tall he is [ __ ] tall and Mike Pence
couldn't look like [ __ ] Ken's dad
from what's the [ __ ] Alice Barbie
whatever the [ __ ] that girl's name is
Barbie Barbie and Ken Alice sat attached
did you see that they made then amputee
Barbie cool so anyway you just get the
regular Barbie and break the arm off but
dude there should be a quarantine Barbie
Barbie with the mask on standing next to
Mike Pence without the mask how much of
a [ __ ] dick can you be to not be
wearing a mask with a rumor getting nine
people on it and one of the guys is in a
recliner dude the guy's got a recliner
and he's chilling so hard with the mask
just put it on man
but yeah the coronavirus is no joke and
now [ __ ] the techs chained with
Cummings and Rogan and [ __ ] Swardson
is just crazy dude
they just keep sending stuff over
freaking me the [ __ ] out they're like
I'm not worried about it and then all of
a sudden
dink-dink pink new text pink pink and
it's just
you know a ship sank because of
coronavirus and we're like we can't go
on ships anymore but yeah dude I love
when I write stuff down in the podcast
and it's one word and I have no [ __ ]
idea but I love how I also love how the
I love how the I don't know what that
means I love how the disinfectant thing
that Trump said was just insane dude and
now he's trying to act like it was
sarcasm which is the best disinfectant
Trump dude the guy's such a goofball and
he says I was sarcastic and he's just
like and it's just a sit not sarcastic
dude dude dude cool
it's so cool to say dude did you know
that instead of dude now this is one of
those YouTube videos let's check this
out this is one of those YouTube videos
that when I check it it won't it'll I'll
have it and it won't have the [ __ ]
actual YouTube video it'll have somebody
talking about the eww happy talk and the
government who's this guy to protect us
with testing he turned his attention
with this a magic pill he Matt you know
that committee I couldn't look more like
he sounds and that guy who the White
House is scrambling to mitigate present
from suggestion that injecting or
consuming something that should not be
consumed or injected under any
circumstances Wow Chris Hayes points out
is a part of pattern which was a magic
bullet to save him and so Chris Hayes is
the guy Chris Hayes looks like the guy
who brings one piece of candy and eats
it in front of the class and everyone's
like is there's any for anyone else and
he goes and he secretly thinks that your
mom you know your mom's don't love you
but when Trump says the thing about
[ __ ] it would make the economy and
the stock market come risk I wanna
obviously dissing from saying this I
don't want to violate or dealing with
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light
and I think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're gonna test it and
then I said supposing you've got the
light inside the bottle of what if you
can do either through the skin or in
some other way and I think you said
you're gonna test that too
then I see the disinfectant knocks it
out in a minute one minute and is there
a way we can do something like that
she's not even answering that's an aside
the knowledge the cleaning because you
see it gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number will also be
interesting to check that oh yeah be
very interesting it would actually be
very interesting to check that it would
be so [ __ ] interesting to inject
somebody with [ __ ] Lysol but you know
what let's not do it because I can't do
that because it's not medical supply and
also injecting it it would be it goes on
the lungs was my favorite part it goes
on the lungs first of all it would go in
the lungs it goes on the lungs
this guy's watched too many [ __ ]
Avenger movies we just put an
ultraviolet light and yeah I know I
understand I understand what he meant to
it okay I understand about the
ultraviolet light and all the [ __ ] but
guess what I'm not a scientist also
doesn't work okay I can't wait for the
comments oh dude you just stop talking
about politics you obviously don't know
what you're talking about
no [ __ ] I don't know what I'm talking
about okay but the thing is I'm not
president I'm not a [ __ ] sack of
potatoes do it uh yeah and the lady with
[ __ ] nine scars this lady is always
looking like she just got twisted up in
some curtains and it was like [ __ ] but
I'm late for the briefing and then ran
and he's talking about how you can just
inject the [ __ ] and like let me tell you
something dude my uh what do you call it
my radar for sarcasm my radar is pretty
damn good you know I'm a I'm a I'm a
comedian I literally almost said I'm a
computer and if I did that I would have
just left I would have left I would have
drove out of my house and I would have
you wouldn't have [ __ ] seen me for a
long long time
alright because I would have just given
up on life I would have cried I would
just listen to that [ __ ] Tim's FM
Devon a funny face
is Shervin basis learning visas while I
was driving in it's kid it's kinda funny
[ __ ] furnace sad for some reason i
think the word funny is in that song so
many times um but i would have been
crying just mad world mad world well
well if I said computer instead of
comedian now now now boys I'm a computer
hey kiddo I'm a computer like that
[ __ ] I'll GI Joe thing that went viral
but anyway I'm a comedian I am I'm
pretty good at understanding what what a
[ __ ] goddamn sarcasm is and also a
president don't be sarcastic number one
job shouldn't be sarcastic
fireman number two president okay get
out the building's burning oh my god
really
psych does is the same thing if you're
the [ __ ] president inject Lysol oh
you were kiddin well eighteen people
[ __ ] died from doing it cuz you're
the leader of the free world anyway I
shouldn't have done it why can't he just
be like I don't know what I was talking
about I didn't mean to say it that way I
know how it came off oops why it doesn't
he just do that why doesn't he just do
that everyone would be like oh alright
well yeah that was a goof whatever but
he's like well it can't be wrong so I
was gonna I was sarcastic [ __ ]
sarcastic dude also he didn't do the
jerk-off motion you know he should have
done that if he was being sarcastic
yeah yeah inject Lysol in your veins or
went went anyway
Biden got endorsed by Hillary Clinton
which is just like and he was just like
I'm with her and he retweeted it so hey
Biden you know let's not let's not do
that because that'll definitely make
sure that you don't you don't you don't
win you understand what I'm saying Biden
with that [ __ ] tongues would have
[ __ ] at tongue swoop that [ __ ]
Trump retweeted the jiff the deep it's
not a D fake I don't think but the Biden
after he was talking about beef jerky
probably did that or some [ __ ] but I
don't bring up anything dude Wyden he'll
bring up anything fine what are you
gonna do with the economy yeah you ever
you ever put together a chair um yeah so
say yes so he's just like I'm with her
and everyone goes like this oh you're
like Hillary cool well then you don't
believe in pizza gate you lost my vote
[Music]
so yeah so so I don't know but that
[ __ ] thing was scary as [ __ ] and then
people and then I sent it to the group
Texan Nick Swardson said is that real
and I go okay I can't you know no it's
not real cuz he looks like a [ __ ]
demon but uh yeah so he was he retweeted
that and people are like up in arms dude
labels are absolutely up in arms about
this it's taking that Trump used and
weaponized a deep fake the freedom you
wouldn't think that the first person who
weaponized deep fake is the President of
the United States of America you'd
imagine it would come from a peel box
that was out of out of commission but it
comes from I saw something that said
you'd think it would come from this
place but a king from 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue
yeah dude I understand people are real
[ __ ] dumb I understand people are so
so stupid like you can't you know that
whole inciting a riot thing but it's
like if you're real stupid and you think
that a [ __ ] that that Biden thing is
real you're the first to go bro you got
to get on the front line and just get a
rat-tat-tat it up do to fight for our
country and get out Pat it up so [ __ ]
king jong-hoon or ill King King King
Kong John em King Kong John Bull own Kim
jong-il Kim Jong un I don't know dude
okay [ __ ] Kimmy
Buller I don't know Kim King do King
King James Jung hoon ill King John King
Kim jong-in the Ming Ming ending in the
beam ending King James Jong hoon in the
beginning ill died okay he's dead
he just [ __ ] was doing that North
Korean [ __ ] March and just went a
little bit too high and his [ __ ]
groin split open I don't know what
happened and his balls went rolling down
the hill and he goes oh [ __ ]
you ever see someone try to [ __ ] run
after balls going down a hill that's the
most [ __ ] you can look dude and balls
rolled down a hill guess what goodbye
balls dude I would never risk my life
trying to go get balls [ __ ] rolling
down a hill and one time when I was on
rollerblades
I was I was dude I would go fast on
rollerblades rollerblades was my [ __ ]
the 90s forget it dude I would [ __ ]
boom and I would [ __ ] boom and I
would kick back one while my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sliced I would slice him up like this
with my [ __ ] hand and I'd slice it up
on the other hand and my [ __ ] right
leg would go back when I sliced my left
hand and my left leg would go back when
I sliced my right hand bro
I was arrow died the [ __ ] Namek okay
ever since the beam inking and I [ __ ]
was doing this [ __ ] I saw a big hill and
I was like can you take it and I was I
Yi up you know how everyone's two voices
in your head if you say you're not
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude you
go like this to yourself can I do it yep
if you ever think I can do it without
somebody in your head asking you can you
do it you're a [ __ ] sociopath for
real so I go like this can I do it and
then I go yup and then I hit that
[ __ ] hill and I was always good at
being arrow the [ __ ] dynamic but I was
never good at stopping people would do
that tea stop and I will be like how do
you do dude
how do you do the tea stop without
swerving do it I would you do the tea
stop then your [ __ ] wheels are just
perpendicular and then you just end up
swinging and then you fall on your back
and your head gets hit on the [ __ ]
gravel and I didn't wear a helmet
because I ain't no mark I didn't wear a
helmet cause I know [ __ ]
this was [ __ ] New Jersey dude you
think I'm gonna be [ __ ] slicing and
kick him back with a with a with a
helmet on come on man might as well be
wearing shoulder pads and you know your
boy got no shoulder pads
I mean elbow pads shoulder pads [ __ ]
be an arrow the [ __ ] dynamic shoulder
pad just shoulder pads while you're
[ __ ] rollerblading anyway
rollerblading is [ __ ] by the way you
put on rollerskates okay they figured it
out
in the however whatever decade it was
and then in the 90s we were like what if
we make it more difficult and what if we
make it so people hurt themselves more
[ __ ] that dude anyway so I went down
that hill and bro I was fast and I
thought oh [ __ ] I went on too fast now
I'm at the point where I'm too fast I
can't stop I'm gonna have to throw my
body into something so I was looking at
car parked cars I was looking at other
you know trash cans I was like maybe
that maybe that no and it was just
getting faster it would start you know
sure and I would see things go by [ __ ] I
should have hit that one cuz now I'm
just getting fatter
[Music]
so I was like I'm just gonna jump on the
grass and in New Jersey they got the
sidewalks and I jumped I jumped off the
gravel and onto the [ __ ] first patch
of grass because there was always the
first patch of grass and then there was
the sidewalk and then the person's yard
I jumped off on that first patch of
grass now I was gonna do a hop over the
[ __ ] sidewalk from the first patch of
grass into somebody's yard and I had it
all planned out in my head and AH as we
know things don't always go to north go
to go as planned so what I did was I
jumped off on the hit the first parts of
the first part of the path of the grass
and then [ __ ] just fell down so hard
and skinned my knees and it had a
[ __ ] skin flap over my knees because
of the sidewalk I got scraped on it and
it's all good but I'm fine and that's my
point dude I'm never ever running after
a ball running down a [ __ ] hill but
my point is King James in the beginning
kim jeong-hoon
illest [ __ ] rapper alive is dead okay
so and i don't know why but he had
surgery and he hit dude they gotta kill
the guy they got to kill the surgeon
there is ZERO choice it's a matter of
fact it should just be an honorable
thing that you do for your country
is legit work on the leader King jong-il
Kim Jong Un's and then [ __ ] you
prepare to die whether you fix them or
not you go like this thank you for your
service and then you go and then you
just go and then you go and then you in
slow motion and it's kind of funny
[ __ ] then your friends mad world and
his tears were even shooting out of his
eyes in slow-motion mad world and then
they go like this [ __ ] it let's go in
the meantime make sure there's no
internet still I [ __ ] and so yeah that's
it dude you don't you do not you do not
[ __ ] work on King Kim jong-il Kim
Jong hoon without getting [ __ ] killed
so it doesn't matters for a nose job or
a heart transplant that's it I wish it
was just for a nose job
if Kim Jung hoon was going in for a
[ __ ] nose job and the guy just goes
like this okay here we go
uh uh scalpel please
mad world mad world get the other guy in
here too lady's dead oh all right well
we gotta [ __ ] use his sister now do
you see her sister dude her sister that
one pic of her just like this dude least
Kim jong-un looked like a [ __ ] like a
kid that would uh just like run away
with the ball you know literally and I'm
you know he was look he would chase
after the ball down the street and also
run after the ball anybody come on dude
and he had the ball he's like [ __ ]
Kim's talking with that Kim had the ball
we can't [ __ ] use it and it's his
ball you know no matter what we say we
don't have a ball and it's his ball but
yes so the guy that nerd dude how
nervous would you be if you were Kim
Jong Un's [ __ ] surgeon how nervous
would you be if you were King Jong Un's
surgeon just okay um one time I went
into a [ __ ] boot place I wanted to
buy boots I was like 22 I was with my
friend Brandon and this and this and
this Indian guy was uh was was the
salesman and he was so nervous and
Brendan and I couldn't stop laughing I
was like one of those [ __ ] high
school things actually no I was in high
school [ __ ] this 21 year old [ __ ]
and he and I was like hey do you have
these boots and he was like um actually
um let me look and he was so nervous it
was like somebody was there with a gun
to his head or a gun in the thing and we
live you know when these kids come in
don't [ __ ] with us man we will kill you
don't mention we're here so we came in
and the guy was like let me see I'm Andy
we'll go to the back and be like I'm
actually we do not have those um we do
not have those style in we don't have
your size and then everything I asked
you'd be like actually and we used to
have them
and every time I think of someone really
nervous in a situation I think of that
guy goddamn so that guy I imagine that
guy as Kim Jong Un's
surgeon just like okay we're here he
needs to have a [ __ ] you know some
stuff done but actually I'm okay we used
to have those instruments but we don't
have those now but let me see in the
back and it goes in the back what do we
have we need to have something like that
just just use a butter knife okay I mean
I feel okay we come out we have this yes
we can do this and then just touching it
oh boy
no please doc I used to be alive
I actually I used to be alive but I'm
dead now I'm on my way to dying so
anyway how nervous would you be if you
were a [ __ ] Kim Jong Un's
surgeon Oh for [ __ ] sake dude was that
the main guy that always worked on my
house stressful first of all if that was
the guy that always you is Kim Jong un
Serge I mean I know how many surgeries
he had you have never gonna lie on
suction but not because you fat in the
face so um no not cause it's not but I
guess it doesn't matter they'll do it if
I was a leader of a whole [ __ ]
country
you know how fat I would be bro I swear
to God I would be so fat and only wear a
shirt and a short one [ __ ] that long
shirt over the dick short shirt a medium
size and I'm fat and my dick and balls
are out you came to see him anymore
doesn't matter cuz my fats coming up and
I would just get sucked every day by the
way would have a wife and she'd be cool
with it because I have billions and
billions of dollars and people that
would literally kill themselves for me I
gotta get there I got to get there I got
to get a country I got to get a [ __ ]
country [ __ ] this cult podcast no cult
ain't country ding ding ding survey says
country that's what I got to be a
[ __ ] country owner I need to be a
[ __ ] country owner the fattest [ __ ]
why is anybody getting surgery it
doesn't matter I got to do these ads but
still I got to get a country and if it
was a new surgeon Wow
if it was a new surgeon oh my god you
know what I mean
be like you're the next surgeon for King
John okay people he's probably gonna
need it and then like you know what he
needs to have surgery Oh for [ __ ] sake
all right well Jesus Christ man it was
nice knowing ya here I go I gotta go
work on [ __ ] King James John oon the
illest rapper alive in the main game
Gayle alright do it let's get these
[ __ ]
I mean can I find him no are they
somewhere on my [ __ ] yes
is it cool that I can't find him it's
[ __ ] amazing I can't find him does it
piss me off gotta go into my [ __ ] it
emails again and do it and it's all good
here it is found it again
easy enough only a little bit of lag
time yes dude Bambi
look I'm gonna level with you all right
it's very rare at a level with you guys
but when running a business HR issues
can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and HR
manager salaries aren't cheap
alright an average of $70,000 a year huh
that's crazy bambi spelled BA MBE e was
created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just you
probably be like for about 40k no dude
$99 a month in Gua with baby you can
change HR from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength come on babies
month to month no hidden fees $99 a
month that's so simple because you want
to spend time on HR complaints so come
on get it done with Bambi go to Bambi
calm slash Congrats right now to
schedule your free HR audit that's Bambi
calm / Congrats spell baam bae dot-com /
Congrats honey look I'm gonna level with
you guys okay we all shop online a lot
especially now but did you know that you
can make online shopping even better
because I I didn't know that because I
have so much fun doing online shopping
alright well you can make it even better
and easier with honey honey is the free
online shopping tool that saves you
money online
honey automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your cart
which makes online shopping finally feel
as easy as its supposed to be
honey has found it's over 18 million
members over 2 billion dollars in
savings all right so you guys it doesn't
matter if you're 14 or 40 or 400 it's
easy you know sometimes like a little
bit older people are like well what do I
do
this is so
for them users love honey that's why it
has over a hundred thousand five star
reviews on Google on the google chrome
store when you check out it's easy to
check out this the the little box drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds for it
to scan for every promo code on the
internet everyone on the internet and
then watch the prices drop uh I just got
a stuff a bunch of stuff from sur La
Table boom from Hani dable I love it cuz
I'm like foreign you know not using
honey is literally passing up free money
I want you to understand that it's free
to use and installs in just a few
seconds plus it's backed by PayPal so
you know it's good get honey for free @
join honey calm / Congrats that's join
honey dot-com / Congrats dude one time
my brother [ __ ] meant to text me and
my friends about [ __ ] and and texted
my dad by mistake
[Music]
he wrote love jizz in her something as a
joke and my dad and it was - me and my
dad dude here I was and then I was like
oh what was it again because I knew it
was a nasty thing and my brothers and I
was like Matt what was the thing again
that you mistakenly texted to that to
the family and he was like dude it
wasn't in the family was just to you and
dad thank God imagine if I texted to mom
but it was something about [ __ ] and I
went
Oh for nine days anyway dude I should
call him but I'm that [ __ ] it cuz I've
gotta want to I don't want to cold call
him ah you never know what if he's doing
that [ __ ] eat eat you know I mean
what if he's doing the horizontal model
what is he laying arm let it belittle
what if he's what if he's laying
horizontal nine not because he's on a
ventilator you know I'm talking about
you know I'm talking about sex yeah so
that's hilarious
have you ever mistakenly dude send him
to me I've been actually haven't been
looking at stuff online lately cuz I
feel better doing it dude
God the [ __ ] simps right and you know
it's just like you know nope
but yeah so he just used disinfecting
worse Trump impression of all time it's
okay if you watch my Netflix special I
really appreciate it
no pain check it out need to need to
watch that if you haven't watched it
please watch it it's doing really well
thank you I really appreciate you
listening and watching watching it
another thing I checked out on Netflix
mm-hmm because that's what my girl and I
was like should we watch this and she
goes [ __ ] yeah it was called too hot to
handle and you know you know you
actually know okay it's with chicks that
are [ __ ] apparently so hot but not
that hot and they're like you know the
chicks are hot I'm not gonna be the guy
that's like no dude I love it when
people guys are just like she's actually
not that hot and you're like who and
they're like Gisele Bundchen and you're
like okay well she's the hottest girl in
the world and you're like nah bro she's
not that hot who JLo came in you know
she's not that hot who [ __ ] Margot
Robbie alright okay man alright dude
like you wouldn't [ __ ] bust Australia
in your pants if you saw her walking
down the street
it dude Margot Robbie so hot if I start
walking on the street I just go like
this no and keep walking
you ever see a girl so hot they can just
go like this for [ __ ] you want to in
your head you go yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
just keep walking just their [ __ ]
Jimbo's are just [ __ ] boring the line
just going dude [ __ ] you ever see the
girl with the Jimbo's that just when
they when they when she goes and my it
hits the downbeat they [ __ ] move up
are you kidding me dude when a girl hits
the downbeat and the and the [ __ ]
jimbo simultaneously move up like
there's some notes oh they [ __ ] Jimbo
simultaneously move up like they're
[ __ ] some hot some Pisces get out of
here and I named talking about liquid
I'm talking about ah dude when girls get
those [ __ ] Jimbo's that
simultaneously look up like that like
some eyeballs that are up to something
forget it dude I want to go like this
get out of town hop in a car and drive
away through the window dude it makes me
so mad when I see a [ __ ] hot girl I
just special e if it's hot outside I
just go alright okay okay okay
take me to jail [ __ ] I just want to say
some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so
annoying when I see a hot chick they're
just out you know they're not you know
sometimes they're not doing [ __ ] they're
just chillin walking around like whoo
dude girls love getting [ __ ] done you
ever see a girl walking around with like
a folder forget a move out the [ __ ]
way she'll run you over
I sorry I just need to I I need I need
to I I have to yeah all right okay dude
whatever dude you got those high C's man
you got them Jimbo's that look like
they're up then some anyway do it what
was that even [ __ ] [ __ ]
talking about what was I talking about
got zero clue I have zero [ __ ] clue
jizz my brother text in jizan I don't
know man who cares dude anyway when I
see hot chicks I get mad dude I need to
you know one time I was walking by a hot
chick and I turned around to check her
out I was in Sacramento I think and some
girl goes some girl look it walks after
her not her friend
and she says oh my god really and I go
yeah
don't [ __ ] you know what I mean
that's my midbrain it's not like I'm I'm
going dude who's [ __ ] it's like you
know what's bilborough's line where he's
like yeah I'm not a feminist he's like
but I can still support them it's like I
gotta get back and I'm [ __ ] up the
joke and you listen to it I don't even
want to watch his [ __ ] he's great but
yeah do it
speaking of feminist do it this kind of
[ __ ] was funny I thought I didn't know
about this my buddy clued me into it
mark the Irish guy who always has too
many drinks Adele had a divorce this is
some gangster [ __ ] it does a gangster
okay
I love Adele because she could sing and
oh it's talking about hot chicks and
[ __ ] was I talking about I don't
remember whatever anyway Adele had a
divorce and gave her a husband just
three like three fourths of her money
and that dude I think his name Simon
course it is dude if you were gonna pick
a name for a guy who was gonna take a
girl's money and be cool with it his
name would be Simon the only guys named
Simon are guys who could do that or a
[ __ ] scientists that like can cure
cancer but instead use their powers for
evil
but so this guy took a hundred and forty
million out of our 190 million and that
is so [ __ ] look at this did Adele
really pay three quarters of her net
worth to her ex-husband and divorce
settlement you know don't come to me for
facts this is either true or not true
and I'm gonna say it's true and now
we're gonna make fun of it but yeah
judge reportedly rules for a delta pay
her ex-husband of three years over 140
million in nasty divorce settlement two
to three years look at this guy cheese
in next door the guy just looks like
some [ __ ] he looks like
I'll be on the Joe Rogan podcast once
and never again and it's not this is on
the the blemish comm which is highly
reputable obviously because it's called
the blemish Adele recently finalized the
divorce seven with ex hymen exercise
Bensimon connect II it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] guy from Greece connect II go
greased lightning you're never gonna
frickin roll Greece I didn't go greased
lightning i mispronounced so much [ __ ]
on this podcast it's unbelievable it's a
foreign language the settlement is
sealed and they're not talking about
what was in it but we don't actually
know but it says the rumor is that she
paid 140 million on her 194 million
fortune tour X seems to be based on
reports that hey honey my before team in
Dodge Feldman look at these [ __ ]
things I hope it dealt these are tweets
I hope Adel kills her husband and keeps
her net worth that man didn't write any
of those songs dude this is probably
from the same type of girl that [ __ ]
you know thinks if I if Bryan Callen
divorced his wife that she's supposed to
make half a his money which is 20 grand
[Music]
[Applause]
and then some other lady said if I was
Adele I would do something ridiculous
like go gamble and purposely lose all my
money so my ex-husband can't have it not
how it works okay still got to pay it
hopefully that person's 12 maybe it is
because her [ __ ] Twitter is at
[ __ ] cow 666 ok cool change it dude
what's wrong with people
[ __ ] cow 666 sit disgraceful and also
mentioning the devil uh and then this
[ __ ] is the best this this is even
better to me that man helped build Adele
into whatever star she is today let's
not just say things because we have a
mouth ma'am
like the guy who is so angry at gettin
[ __ ] at guys getting [ __ ] by having
to pay for half
I don't know what I feel about this yeah
I mean no I do actually know what I feel
about this [ __ ] if I was married to
Adele for three years and she wanted a
divorce if she came up look at this guy
wrote King secured his bag all we can do
is stand dude
don't use too [ __ ] dumb shits Lang's
in one thing like King and secured his
bag and stand that's three this guy such
a [ __ ] product you know all we can do
is stand dude uh if I'm married to Adele
and she's just like I want divorce and
I'm just like okay how much you're gonna
give me nothing I'll just go just
alright dude just make sure I got a flat
screen and a couch I'm good I'll go I'll
try to write a book that you gonna make
me not you want me to write a book or
not you don't want me to write a book no
I would prefer if you don't alright I
won't do it I just let me cuz you know
what's awesome being taken is cool
having a family is amazing it's
beautiful it's fulfilling but you know
what's this [ __ ] not having to do
anything you don't want to do whenever
you [ __ ] don't want to do it walking
around the street where are you oh [ __ ]
can you pick up alright any of that
[ __ ] it doesn't matter how free I am
and I'm free dude I'm free I got my
family but I'm free I got it good my
[ __ ] kid can't even talk and my girls
always do whatever you know sometimes
her smiles crack and when she says it
but still ya know go but I got it good
okay but nothing is better than just
getting the [ __ ] out and just walking
around and not having a and just a
lovey-dovey day lovely day lovely day
lovely day oh it's my ex well [ __ ] I
happen to be at coffee bean right now
you want me to pick up what a head of
lettuce well instead of that I'll just
sit this [ __ ] iced americano and when
I'm done with it I'll sip another
and when I'm done with that I don't know
what I will be doing but I know what I
won't be doing getting a [ __ ]
head of lettuce dude any guy that should
[ __ ] that dude for taking this money 140
mill by the way just give me 1 mil maybe
or guess what give me nothing
I'll go get a job I [ __ ] crate and
barrel and rake it in do it I'll be
selling pots like it's you know this
girl right some women are saying if
Adele's husband has any shame he'll ask
them to cut the settlement in half what
that's a [ __ ] a hundred million
dollar still please let my king secure
his bag another one with this [ __ ]
securing the bag is so annoying dude
dude I secured the bag
hey man just so you know I could secure
the back who made that popular what's
his name dj khaled and then there's
Khalid there's always that [ __ ] that
happens the artists are them this is
another artist that's always like the
same sounds the same [ __ ]
I mean rappers don't even give a [ __ ]
it's like Lil Wayne lo Zayn little
little chain will [ __ ] to change
three chains big Mike big dike big fight
big like cool did a slur in they're
gonna get cancelled um anyway cool for
Adele being a gangster dude and just
being like Shirl just tight 140 million
all right try to do these second ads did
I X out of it yes not gonna do the ad
yet yeah not gonna do the ads yet
I gotta talk about taught to handle
that's what the [ __ ] I was talking about
[ __ ] yeah I got to finish this before I
do the ads or I could do it afterwards
I'll do it afterwards let me do these
ads dude or as they say on the [ __ ]
one of those power 106 got to pay some
bills or is that [ __ ] 102.7 who cares
doesn't matter I'm my [ __ ] vamp infer
[ __ ] man cuz can't find the email again
got it right here dude episode of 170 of
[ __ ] congratulations
my undies dude I love it it's officially
spring which means it's officially
spring cleaning time which means yes
okay that look first of all that's a
thing and if you're not doing it you
should you got to clean out your
apartment you know what and what Marie
Kondo says how weird is it that Marie
condos name is condo and she cleans out
condos anyway did anyone ever say that
or realize that especially with your
underwear drawer you got to do that
because underwear gets stanky right and
your relationship with toxic old
tattered up undies and move on to a
membership with the softest undies to
ever grace your nethers a freshness
start for spring I love me undies I wear
them all the time
I get fun powders I don't wear them as
much as the solid colors because I'm
bold let's face it babies I'm bold why
would you need a me on deep membership
that's very interesting honestly because
it's fun how about that are you do you
like fun yeah it's an easy way to give
your future self a present each month
it's very cool to get packages and when
they're nice very smooth cool colorful
bitchin ass undies even better a
membership with me on DS a full of perks
like site-wide savings early access free
shipping and new ridiculously soft
undies delivered to your door each month
and you can build your under collection
I have a great under collection for me
on these my undies has great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee so that's awesome
to get your 50% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies calm / Congrats that's
me on DS dot-com / congrats shipstation
as folks adapt to this ever-changing
world we are all going to be buying more
stuff online than ever before if you're
an e-commerce e-commerce seller you're
ready to meet the demands of new
delivery culture are you be ready with
ship ship station why ship station well
when you're selling online getting a lot
of orders out fast can be tough how do
you keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use are you
getting the best rates these are all
things that you need to go to ship
station calm to figure out
use them you shipstation gog.com it's
the fastest easiest and most affordable
way to manage make sure that's still
going most affordable way to manage and
ship your order is just a few clicks and
you'll be managing your orders printing
out labels and getting your product to
happy customers ship station makes it
easy I use ship station on all my merch
and you know my merch is fire and you
know you get it and you love it
my fans are always tweeting me about how
they get their orders sometimes they
order does that oh yeah I just got on
like what how'd you do that so quickly
ship station it's very easy it's the way
to go right now congratulations
listeners can try ship station free for
60 days when you use offer code congrats
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of delivery culture it's
changing get started at ship station
calm today click the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in congrats
that ship station comm then enter offer
code Congrats ship station comm make
ship happen dude you know what man I've
worked out my back yesterday
killed it did [ __ ] 35 pound chin-ups
and I didn't do the [ __ ] once I did the
[ __ ] overhanded once dude I got a
wide-body okay because of that thank you
very much if you think I have a
wide-body and I did [ __ ] all sorts
other back exercises and before that I
did legs I did split squats and I used
my Audi [ __ ] wheel to keep my leg
propped up and my legs still burned now
today is chest day did I do it no am I
gonna do it after this podcast no I'll
do it tomorrow okay even though I told
my friend I go on a hike with him now I
won't cuz I'll just do chest day and all
my abs going away slightly yes because I
don't [ __ ] work out as hard as I did
when I had the trainer but I'm still
keeping it real babies I still see Jake
Gyllenhaal and Heath Ledger [ __ ] on
my back that's where they shot
vast terrain man so too hot to handle I
saw this show too hot to handle uh
Netflix you know supposedly these hot
chicks and these hot dudes and I don't I
look some of the girls are hot I'm not
gonna [ __ ] lie okay actually hots the
good word for it
maybe one or two would maybe be
classified as beautiful but hot okay
there's one girl that I could see myself
maybe chilling with sex the horizontal
mambo sure maybe a few of them actually
chillin with one of them maybe one of
them there's like two or three dudes
that are okay cool kind of handsome but
some of these dudes are just [ __ ]
donkeys they just like look not that
good and they're just [ __ ] dummies
[ __ ] and I'm watching too hot to handle
I saw about three episodes and that's
totally the type of show that I would
watch however many episodes I watched in
the first sitting is however many
episodes I'm gonna watch I'm never going
back to this show but I got three
episodes in and here's the thing these
hot people come to an island and it's
awesome and they're all sexually
promiscuous people and twelve hours into
it which I don't know why they waited 12
hours into it this Alexa type [ __ ]
thing that looks like an air freshener
is just like you win $100,000 if you
don't have sex with each other for a
month and you can't that's a pot of
money if you guys don't [ __ ] if you
don't kiss if you don't pet heavily you
won't lose any money if you do any of
this stuff you lose some of the money
and what happens is if you kiss you'll
lose this amount of money if you
you also can't masturbate at all okay
you can't masturbate if you masturbate
you get docked money too now what
happens is that all money that comes
from the pot I thought originally
everyone gets a hundred thousand dollars
and then if they [ __ ]
they lose the money I thought that was
good enough but when you lose a hundred
thousands when you have a hundred
thousand dollars as ten people that
means you have ten thousand dollars and
if somebody kisses somebody else if you
[ __ ] open the mouth and you a little
and you put that [ __ ] tongue in there
you lose three grand of the total lump
sum of the money so that means that
everyone gets docked a few hundred
dollars if somebody [ __ ] kisses so
that means if you kiss you're a genuine
selfish [ __ ] all right now that being
said I'd have [ __ ] everybody by
[ __ ] day four and the end the dudes
too because not cuz I'm gay because dude
I'm on an island and this boners finding
someone Dylan and and then I swear to
God do it if I'm on an island
I'm always the most activated when I get
out of some water if I get out of the
shower and get out of the pool did I
give it 30 minutes until my [ __ ] just
breka quook quook quook i don't know why
but it's like the roadrunner arriving
somewhere boy go go go go go quick
that's my [ __ ] my balls are like what
the [ __ ] how'd we get here so quick when
I get into the pool forget it do it I
don't know what it is
I think it's cuz my dick is
overcompensated because when you get in
the pool you dick gets smaller and your
balls get smaller because it gets
[ __ ] because of the what they call
shrinkage I don't like that term but
then when you [ __ ] get out afterwards
my dicks like yeah we're gonna have a
none of that breka quook quook quook and
[Music]
so yeah but I would be [ __ ] everybody
all the money out the window don't give
a [ __ ] but I thought the funniest thing
would be cuz here's what happens when it
happen you kiss the first people ki saw
like three episodes and somebody kissed
in like the second episode of first
episode and then the next episode is
like well somebody broke the rules the
the [ __ ] whatever they call it the
lady that looks like an air freshener
the electric-type girl is like somebody
broke the rules you get
you dock 3000 and they were like who did
it and then the guys like alright dude
I'm gonna come clean I feel bad really
sorry but I kissed and she did it to me
and the girl the hot chick was like what
you kissed me and he did it was his
fault but that [ __ ] ass was trying to
act like it was her fault that's not a
man bro I'm sorry I would have been like
dude I'm sorry I doct everyone 3r and
I'll [ __ ] reimburse everybody but look
at that girl right there you're telling
me come on dude look at her she made me
go breca CAC CAC CAC she made my [ __ ]
arrive like the roadrunner and then
you'd be like all right dude I get it
fine you're gonna reimburse us cool [ __ ]
that you know what I would actually do I
wouldn't [ __ ] anybody I'm sure if you
[ __ ] you get docked like five grand
kissing his three grand I don't know how
much you get docked for masturbating but
dude how funny would it be if there was
like a chronic masturbator there and he
couldn't help it he didn't know that he
couldn't do it until he got there cuz
they don't drop the rules on you till
you got there and they'd be like so
somebody broke the rules at the end of
the day and the guy was and they were
like somebody masturbated 12 times today
and they were just like oh [ __ ] it what
you are docked 11 grand and they're like
who [ __ ] sure everyone jerked off
they'd be like everyone jerked off and
be like know who jerked off even better
I didn't do I didn't do it and then it'd
be just one nervous guy with like a red
face and a shriveled up dick just like
ah I don't know I mean it was me I don't
know you know I jerked up a few times
how many and he just asked the Alexa
girl Oh 12 and if she's like I'm sorry
dude I try I didn't know you weren't
supposed to do this they should have
done the research man I have a [ __ ]
chronic masturbation everyday just
jerking off 12 times a day I can't help
it I'm sorry they wouldn't leave you
alone they tie your [ __ ] hands behind
your back link it to my [ __ ] dick
yeah let me get to my [ __ ] dick
goddamn [ __ ] this Alexa girl I need to
spell loose our titties went up on the
downbeat [ __ ] this [ __ ] off you losing
this money it's like the worst Guy
Ritchie movie of all time
he's losing uh some money yeah but it
keeps getting bonus keeps getting bonus
what we do well we could got
I've got a better idea let's tie his
hands behind his back and Froemming the
ocean there's like MacGyver he's got his
[ __ ] his hands are tied behind his
back but he's using a [ __ ] sharp
bamboo stick to try and cut it so he can
just jerk his [ __ ] off money just
[ __ ] going down as the superimposed
the money just over as his over his dick
he's jerking his dick off and over it
his superimposed graph of money just
dwindling hahaha like it's a [ __ ]
he's just jerking off so hard in the
[ __ ] Olli and over it just different
shots of his dick just ching ching ching
just keeps going that's it did you just
like this like
um Wow dude that's hilarious
and on this island they've got a chronic
master but why didn't they not they
should have brought the chronic match
and they entered three episodes in here
comes the chronic masturbator let's see
if they can get this guy to stop jerking
it and [ __ ] just enter chicks with
just beautiful booby Luby's I gotta
think of a new word for boobs man
I'm not saying tits I don't wanna say
boobs one of my fourteen breasts then
you're just like a creep am I really
like are breasts I have a body that
keeps [ __ ] you know girls like loves
to see celebrities nude and it's just
like so weird and he's just like I've
seen all anytime a girls ever like I
don't know who [ __ ] it has done nude
scenes or not but if I need to know I
can ask my buddy like if I'm like I
happen to know Halle Berry went nude in
swordfish cuz when that movie came out I
remember they were giver and actor like
however many millions of dollars to show
her [ __ ] boobie luby's and my buddy
knows all about that [ __ ] if I'm like
hey what's her name you know has [ __ ]
Angie Harmon ever showed her boobs he'd
be like yeah actually she should her
booths in one episode of of red Shoe
Diaries on HBO in 1993 did I used to
watch him [ __ ] I used to watch red Shoe
Diaries and just we're gonna wait and
what was the other one will go on HBO is
red Shoe Diaries and the other one in
the other one right welcome to medicine
now it was like love not love line but
like love Street that's what it was
remembers dude red Shoe Diaries in love
Street was [ __ ] Sports City for a 15
year old welcome to lab Street right I
think that's what it was dude oh man
love Street let's Street
I think it was that HBO loved street yup
dude love Street HBO
Oh was this it was this a documentary
one was this it let me let me try and
get this here can you find it love
Street I think it is no it's not love
Street it's not coming up but it said it
was though when I looked on love Street
IMDB video this is it yeah love Street
here it is compilation of three stories
from love Street erotic anthology series
they are trick-or-treat galletas wish
and most pleasurable death oh how about
[ __ ] Emmanuelle series I used to watch
that [ __ ] too and it was on HBO I was
like the same chick I think she was just
on it man you it was like a manual goes
to Paris and many well does this and
many was like it's basically like the
Ernest movies only it she showed her
titties and it was about splurging hey
Vern I'm gonna see some tits today worse
[ __ ] impression of that guy ever but
loves I've earned dude that [ __ ] even as
a kid that [ __ ] pissed me off I was like
why is he so close to the camera dude
back up my [ __ ] that guy died when he
was like 50 um of course that guy I
don't use fifty you know what I mean
that guy I've earned earned this people
love Street theme song I can't find it
any what was I talking about
Oh too hot to handle
anyway I saw this [ __ ] I used to support
to the love Street yeah it doesn't they
don't have it god damn it
HBO they don't have it oh well welcome
to love Street and let's take the rap
wasn't there oh yeah my buddy who who
[ __ ] loves to see celebrities titties
dude dude he used to have this watch
that would take pictures of waitresses
when they came by
they were black and white wait for it
when the technology is good enough um
dude it looked like a [ __ ]
etch-a-sketch you'd be like look see and
I'm like oh god guy wait for the
technology to get better
dude you I'd be like stop taking
pictures of waitresses man it's so
[ __ ] pervy man maybe like what it
doesn't matter if felt like they're nude
little did I know everyone's off looking
for your night with their goddamn iPhone
God back then it seemed like such a
[ __ ] weird thing to do just take
pictures of people anyway he [ __ ] did
it
yeah and he has like pictures of [ __ ]
celebs with their [ __ ] tits on his
like hard drive or some [ __ ] I'm just
like what are you doing bro just Google
exists anybody who saves any [ __ ]
picture that's already on the Internet
is weird as [ __ ] dude
it's already there welcome to love
Street and let the gratitude I mean I
never like busted too much and like a
lot until I got RLS I want people to
know about this man restless leg
syndrome I have this [ __ ] and it [ __ ]
sucks man it feels like there's a small
jolt of electricity coursing through my
legs only when I'm trying to sleep if
I'm falling asleep at 3:00 p.m. on the
couch I can go right out the second it's
time for bed at 12 o'clock whatever the
[ __ ] whenever I go to bed I stay up late
cuz I'm a [ __ ] badass but I go to bed
and when I do that they [ __ ] always
my legs start activating it's like I
want to [ __ ] it ii want to dance but
it's not time for dancing it's time for
sleep ease and I can't get to sleep I
try nyquil I try [ __ ] melatonin sure
it all works kind of but then what
really happens is I'm just extra tired
and there's still the jolt of
electricity in my legs so it's still
hard to fall soon and I'm talking about
sometimes three hours it takes to fall
save one time it took four hours to go
to sleep and melatonin and night quills
they don't really work that much when
you [ __ ] got to RLS because that's
just like you know spray and lice all
over his [ __ ] you still smell the [ __ ]
but also you smell the terrible [ __ ]
[ __ ]
lysyl out of loss one day a [ __ ]
masturbator now I like talking about
this [ __ ] cuz I'm a real man dude I'm a
very you know I'm a you know I'm a
gentleman you know I don't like talking
about raunchy stuff right you know I'd
like to keep it clean
I'd like to talk about busting I don't
like to talk about you know diarrhea
stuff I'd like to keep it classy as well
I'm trying to say I'm a gentleman so I
tried squirting and guess what dude not
only did I fall asleep I fell right to
sleep I was like what I do all right
[ __ ] it at a loss I'll [ __ ] squirt and
I squirted and right afterwards dude
right afterwards so whenever I got RLS
it's time to [ __ ] do it it's time to
do that dude Braham forty I don't even
want to jerk off sometimes I'm just like
nine I want to do this [ __ ] oh my god
claw [ __ ] do it [ __ ] it and then I do
it and then I always conk out
immediately so if you have restless leg
syndrome try that for real and then
three months to look it up if other
people would I thought I had like a
secret I'm just like the secret guy
jerking off I'd lose so much money on
too hot to handle it because I'd just be
able I would do I gotta fall see like
our restless leg syndrome can I get a
doctor's note and can we not lose money
because I have to masturbate because I
have to fall asleep it's a beautiful
island and I want to get my beauty rest
so I can go into the [ __ ] ocean
tomorrow and see yeah I need a doctor's
note for too hard to handle so I got
that RLS so when I [ __ ] squirt it
though
I fall I fall asleep immediately and so
if you have RLS do that man it works and
I looked it up to see if other people
were like because I thought it was
sneaky I told you and it turns out that
it was in an article of Cosmopolitan in
2011 and I'm not alone so it releases
dopamine when you [ __ ] squirt off and
dopamine can help RLS
so [ __ ] it when I combo it with the
melatonin and squirt then do it forget
it I'm rip then wrinkle in this [ __ ]
I'll wake up at [ __ ] noon the next day
melatonin under the tongue swallow it 30
seconds later
somebody told me to do that doesn't
probably work I should just swallow it
[ __ ] take nyquil and squirt off dude
dearly beloved I'll [ __ ] sleep so hard
I'll die dude I'll [ __ ] take the
melatonin ship the nyquil and squirt off
and all of a sudden ain't that ten ten
ten I'll see those four [ __ ] guys
from Zimbabwe with that coffin and I'm
in it dude I can't sing rap rap rap
I can't hum that there's few songs you
can't hump there's a few songs
you can't hump and it's it's that song
the coffin meme song what is the [ __ ]
coffin meme how's it going I can't play
it cuz he'll [ __ ] flag me coffin
theme apply just take it off by
astronomy uh a strong astronaut
astronomy uh I strong too many syllables
do it
astronomy a-- [ __ ] what's his name
kim jeong-hoon hanging the guys playing
it he's playing it
[Music]
this is a bike ride banjo playing okay
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't don't don't they don't know
okay I guess I can do it
but one song you can't hum no matter
what try it I challenge you babies send
me videos [ __ ] 50 cent what's that
[ __ ] song is it the [ __ ] song 20
questions
is it the 20 questions song why did I
say the [ __ ] song 50 cent is that this
long at the beginning of it is that it
[Music]
it's not that what the [ __ ] song is it
21 questions I wrote 20 questions 40 you
know is it that what you know that song
we used to do it think didn't intend
thing thing thing and under what you
heard about me what's that one
you can't doing what OPI MP that's what
it is
can't [ __ ] hum this song why can't
you do that sounds so bad dude anyway
dude oh my god this first comment under
it if you listen to this in 2020 you
have awesome musical tastes what a
friggin it dork ah what a frigging dork
all right I'm out you guys are great
thanks for listening remember I hit them
friggin I gotta start saving freakin
more that's really cool I missed our
same friggin more cat that's [ __ ] cool
and you can text me at eight one eight
two three nine seventy eighty seven turn
on no pain man tell a friend tell him to
watch your boy do some standup
watch man on fire watching cords we
could watch them all live show dates are
obviously continuously changing trust me
I wanna get out there more than you want
to [ __ ] see me do it I want to make
them I want to as they say on Twitter
secure that bag man I'm trying to secure
[ __ ] Florida bags Atlantic City bags
and all these bags Vegas bags man but
you know how it is all right dude I'm
trying here I'm gonna get out there and
I have some announcements - that will
happen eventually I don't know when but
working on some deals to get some more
content out to you guys and it's awesome
but you guys are great thank you so much
for listening and be safe out there and
don't go out unless you need to just get
rid of this [ __ ] pandemic it's so
brutal and my heart goes out to people
who have gone through that and that who
have lost loved ones it's really really
really tough it really does
so thank you guys and don't put this
infected inside your [ __ ] body Chris
D'Elia and I'm out
[Music]
so what I just hit the red button